[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump is about to
begin a busy evening of glad-handing and
rallying the troops tonight at his
Florida resort the GOP troops that is
but many of the president's supporters
and almost all of his critics are
expressing some serious concerns tonight
about his plan to levy new tariffs on
imported steel and aluminum leaders
around the world are a warning of a
trade war the president says bring it on
part of the president's day was spent at
the funeral for legendary evangelist
Billy Graham and that is where we start
tonight chief White House correspondent
John Roberts has our top story could
even jump wreck it evening to you
president Trump has never been one to
shy away from a fight he has a doozy on
his hands over steel and aluminum
President Trump in Charlotte today
paying last respects to the Reverend
Billy Graham while across the nation
reaction to his announcement of tariffs
on steel and aluminum kept gaining steam
even the man who said Donald Trump could
be the greatest president ever was
stunned I'm very surprised that he's had
very bad advice from somebody down there
those people are gonna have to pay these
tariffs are gonna pay the Americans
citizens and frankly if we don't we
don't win by assessing tariffs basically
to come back to bite us the president
seemed unconcerned about retaliation
from abroad tweeting this morning that
trade wars are good and easy to win the
president insisting we must protect our
country and our workers our steel
industry is in bad shape if you don't
have steel you don't have a country
while his threat of tariffs provoked
howls of outrage from nations that sell
steel and aluminum to the u.s. from
Ohio's Democratic congresswoman Marcy
Kaptur a big
attaboy mr. president I've served in
Congress for over three decades we've
been waiting for this we don't want to
wait for the steel industry collapse has
happened to the automotive industry we
can't afford to have the aluminum
industry collapse in this country it
wasn't just trade that had political
tongues wagging
last night President Trump met again
with the NRA leadership the second time
this week
the NRA s Chris Cox tweeting POTUS and V
POTUS don't want gun control the White
House insisted the president isn't
backtracking on his calls to improve gun
safety he just wants to hear from all
sides the president's made clear he
wants to talk to all of the big
stakeholders in this process he's spoken
with students with parents with teachers
with local law enforcement with state
and federal authorities as well as
members of the NRA he's going to
continue to have those conversations but
Democrats fear the momentum for change
is already fading Senator Chuck Schumer
saying in a statement President Trump
should go with his instincts not the
Clarion and destructive call of the NRA
if he continues to bow to his right-wing
Ringmaster's we will get nothing done on
guns and his presidency will continue to
fail and the controversy surrounding the
firing of former staff Secretary Rob
Porter
bubbled up again today when chief of
staff John Kelly filled in some blanks
for reporters at a pen and pad session
Kelly saying the first he heard about
allegations of spousal abuse was at
about 5:00 p.m. on Tuesday February 6th
involving Porter's second wife Kelly
went to see Porter who told him he'd
resigned about 90 minutes later after a
quick trip to Capitol Hill Kelley
learned of a second allegation this time
from Porter's first wife Porter assured
Kelly there was nothing to the
allegations but Kelly insisted Porter
had to resign that night and the next
day the White House released several
statements in support of Porter even
though he'd effectively been fired he is
going to be leaving the White House it
won't be immediate but he is resigning
from the White House but he's gonna stay
on to ensure that there's a smooth
transition moving forward
Kelly took the blame for that saying he
had not fully briefed the press office
on what had happened when he learned at
the photo of Porter's first wife with a
black eye he changed his statement to
condemn domestic abuse and revealed that
Porter had been removed from the White
House Kelly also said neither he nor
white House Counsel Don Magan were aware
the FBI had sent information about
Porter's security clearance file to the
White House in both March and July Kelly
told reporters today that he never
thought about resigning over the Porter
issue saying that he acted quickly when
he learned about it and did things as
appropriately as he thought he could
saying that there was nothing to
consider resigning over but Kelly did
acknowledge that the White House could
have handled the situation better
telling reporters quote we didn't cover
ourselves in glory in terms of how we
handled that on Wednesday morning it was
confusing
Brett John Roberts live in a windy North
Lawn John thanks